following breaking news on the  coronavirus this morning the cdc and the  fda are recommending coronavirus vaccine  clinics  pause using the single dose johnson and  johnson vaccine  the agencies say they're reviewing six  reported cases of a rare type of blood  clot in people who've gotten that  medicine  each of these six cases involves women  and one woman  died another is in critical condition  now that we should point out nearly 7  million doses of the johnson and johnson  vaccine have already been administered  in the u.s  the fda is holding a press conference on  this with more information in about half  an hour we have a lot more details on  this at 8newsnow.com